tu penses pas des gens qui changent de
sexe je critiquerai plutôt ce qui ne se
range pas de sous mais rapport à la
pollution de la poule
y'a pas que les bovins connaissent pas
voir d où cette affaire est un problème
c'est horrible j'ai connu des gens qui
se faisait opérer comme on dit à
marrakech faire couper les couettes et
elle n'avait pas l'air plus heureux à
l'arrivée
quand ils sont partis et c'est
malheureusement des gens qui se
suicident très jeune on va voir un truc
là dessus justement le chiffre 1 pour
les hommes le chiffre 2 pour les femmes
le système des numéros de la sécurité
sociale semblait jusqu'à leur immuable
pourtant une étude est actuellement en
cours sur la création d'une homo clôture
réservée aux individus changement de
sexe ces derniers seraient identifiés
par le chiffre 3 à l'origine de cette
réflexion
le souci d'une meilleure organisation
mais surtout la volonté d'un contrôle
plus strict des prescriptions un certain
nombre de médecins font des certificats
de complaisance pour dériver certains
traitements hormonaux prévus pour
d'autres applications vers les
transsexuels alors par exemple le
traitement du cancer de la prostate se
traite par des hormones pouvant tout à
fait être utilisé pour les hommes vous
de vouloir devenir des femmes
bon je compte notre but à la sécurité
sociale et de rationaliser les frais et
de faire le maximum d'économies
une fois leur opération réussie les
transsexuels déposent auprès des
tribunaux une demande de changement
d'état civil afin d'obtenir des papiers
conforme à leur apparence de la réussite
de cette étape dépend le succès d'une
nouvelle vie je suis né avec le numéro 1
maintenant j'ai choisi d'être une femme
donc j'ai été opéré
et donc j'espérais pouvoir bénéficier du
numéro 2 maintenant on m'apprend que
donc j'avais un numéro 3 donc pour moi
c'est absolument dramatique parce que si
j'ai le numéro 3 ce ma carte de sécurité
sociale
bon bah c'est terminé quoi les gens ne
me considéreront plus jamais comme je
suis c'est à dire comme une femme
la commission nationale informatique et
libertés est actuellement saisie du
dossier elle peut approuver ou rejeter
l'introduction de ce chiffre 3 il amène
une notion de groupe notion qui est
pratique on comprenons tout à fait pour
la sécurité sociale pour les problèmes
d'organisation et prom de contrôler mes
notions qui heurte notre éthique
le numéro de la sécurité sociale est un
laissez passer pour la santé le travail
et l'éducation
la décision de créer un nouveau groupe
est grave c'est donc le ministre de la
santé qui jugera avant la fin de l'année
ce qu'il est opportun ou non de
poursuivre l'idée de la création de ce
chiffre 3 voilà le reste de la peau est
de l'intox d'abord à nice à l'oreille
[Musique]
non mais jusque là les garçons cg après
les autres elles vous tente peut venir
alors je suis pas un père et j'étais
rire les choses alors plus hauts clos à
toi tu jouais tu me dis si c'est de
l'info ou si c'est de l'intox mon avis à
deux têtes de la toque et toi tu penses
que ces deux là font que c'est de
l'intox
moi je pense que c'est de l'intox
j'avais dit que c'est d'un top mais je
sais pas mais écoute on va savoir c'est
la prochaine l'intox philips est à toi
philibert un bravo claude vous fait des
progrès au fil de cette émission vous
devenu de plus en plus mûr
face aux sujets que nous vous présentons
puisque c'est de l'intox ravin
et travailler à une autre solution c'est
le petit médaillon avec le format alors
vélo sur lui sur les corrections de ne
rien rater de l'ina l'habitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus